你有沒有想過，如果要把二戰的歷史，特別是像東京大空襲這種沉重的話題，講給現在的小朋友聽，要怎麼做他們才會有感？
嗯，這確實是個難題。現在的孩子對教科書可能興趣缺缺，要真的理解戰爭的殘酷，可能很不容易。
對啊。所以今天這個案例就很有意思了，它竟然是透過「Minecraft」這個遊戲來重現東京大空襲。
等等，Minecraft？那個方塊遊戲？把一個嚴肅的歷史事件放進一個遊戲裡，會不會太…兒戲了一點？這怎麼可能真的傳達出戰爭的嚴重性？
其實這就是它出乎意料的地方。日本的一些教育工作者，就是看準了現在的孩子對遊戲的熟悉度。他們讓學童在Minecraft裡重建1945年被燒毀前的東京文京區街景。
重建街景…這聽起來工程很大吧。誰負責做這些？是遊戲公司直接介入，還是老師帶著學生自己摸索？這模式要撐得久嗎？成本划算嗎？
這是由日本的學童自己動手做的。原文裡有提到，就是日本的學童利用Minecraft遊戲，來重新創造戰前東京文京區的街景。他們等於是透過這種方式，親手去「感受」那個時代的建築和氛圍，然後再對比被炸毀後的景象。
讓學童自己做啊，這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字，確實是學生動手。不過，一個遊戲真的能取代傳統的歷史教學嗎？我的意思是，那種沉浸感和歷史的厚重感，能透過方塊呈現出來？
這裡的重點可能不是「取代」，而是「補充」甚至「引導」。當第一手的二戰記憶在日本逐漸消退時，教育工作者正在尋找新的工具。這不是要讓孩子去玩樂，而是透過這種互動的方式，讓他們對歷史產生好奇，進而主動去了解。
這樣說也對，至少比單純讀課本，更容易引起興趣。那如果我是創業者或主管，可以從這裡學到什麼？感覺這種做法離一般公司很遠。
其實不遠。它最大的啟示就是「轉譯」。想想看，很多產業都有「舊」的內容或服務，像觀光業的古蹟、文創業的傳統故事、教育業的知識點。如果能把這些內容，轉譯成年輕客群熟悉的語言或平台，就能觸及到他們。
你的意思是，把嚴肅的內容包裝成年輕人喜歡的形式？就像很多地方文創會把老店故事變成漫畫或動畫？
嗯，差不多是這個意思。這不只是表面包裝，更是在於理解目標客群的「溝通方式」。Minecraft在這裡，就是一個很好的溝通媒介。它顛覆了大家覺得嚴肅的東西就該用嚴肅方式呈現的刻板印象。
那一般上班族呢？這個概念怎麼帶入自己的工作或生活？難道我要在公司用遊戲來開會嗎？
當然不是用遊戲開會啦。不過，你可以想想，你手上的工作內容或報告，有沒有哪些部分是比較枯燥、大家提不起興趣的？有沒有可能換個形式呈現？比如說，用視覺化的圖表、講故事的方式，甚至是一個小型的互動活動？
讓我想想…如果我平常要匯報數據，與其直接丟一堆數字，或許可以試著把這些數據背後的故事挖出來，用圖文並茂的方式呈現，甚至做一個小互動網頁，讓大家自己去點擊探索。
對，就是這個意思。它不只是在講遊戲的應用，更是提醒我們，在做任何溝通或傳達訊息時，要考慮到你的接收者是誰，以及什麼方式最能讓他們理解並產生共鳴。
這樣說來，即使是一個看似很新潮的案例，背後的經營邏輯其實是很實用的。重點是怎麼把那些不容易被消化的內容，找到一個新的入口。
沒錯。好像也提醒了我們，有時候，跳脫既定框架，會發現新的可能。